من الصعب تصديق أن هذه الغابة السحابية الهادئة
في غرب كولومبيا كانت في يوم من الأيام
تحت الحصار ، كانت
معظم الغابات الاستوائية في كولومبيا
بمثابة ملجأ للجماعات المسلحة
لعقود حتى
الآن مع بعض الاستقرار في المنطقة ،
وقد أصبح الوصول إلى هذه الغابة أكثر سهولة
على مدار السنوات العشر الماضية مما يوفر
للعلماء  منظور جديد
لأطول برك شمع النخيل في العالم
هي كائنات لا تصدق
لأنها يمكن أن تنمو لتكون طويلة جدًا
ولكنها ليست أشجارًا ، لذا لا يوجد
خشب في سيقانها ،
يمكن للنباتات الأجنبية أن تنمو إلى أكثر من 60 مترًا
عندما نفكر في  أشجار النخيل ، أنا متأكد من أن معظم
الناس يفكرون في الشواطئ والظروف الدافئة جدًا ،
قنابل الشمع مثل البيئات الأكثر برودة ،
الغابات السحابية على المنحدرات
وأنظمة الارتفاعات العالية
التي تطورت على المنحدرات عبر
جبال الأنديز ولكن لا يوجد مكان وفير كما
هو الحال هنا حيث ستجد أكبر
عدد من السكان  التي تحدث في جميع أنحاء العالم
أساسًا لأنها مستوطنة من
منطقة آندي الاستوائية لذلك لا تنمو في
أي مكان آخر في العالم
كجزء من فريق أو
اكتشفت عالمة النبات الكولومبية ماريا سانين وزملاؤها
في عام 2018 أن بعض
أشجار النخيل في توشيتو قد غيرت جنسها
لأول مرة على الإطلاق ،
وهم يشكون في أن هذه الظاهرة النادرة هي
آلية للبقاء على قيد الحياة ضد إزالة الغابات
وغيرها من الأنشطة البشرية السائدة
في المنطقة مثل سباق
الماشية.  تكمن مشكلة الحفاظ على القنابل الغربية في
أنه ليس لديهم أماكن
تنمو فيها مثل احتياجهم للغابات التي يحتاجونها.
ما يثير قلقنا الآن هو أن
العديد من سكانها أصغر
وأصغر
بينما تضغط سانين وفريقها من
أجل حماية النظم البيئية لنخيل الشمع ،
كما أنهم يساعدون مالكي الأراضي المحليين على
أخذ الحفظ بأيديهم ،
وقد أصبح العديد من الناس على دراية بهذه المشكلة
ولديهم  ينمو الأفراد البالغون في
خصائصهم ،
لذا فهم يجمعون الثمار
وينبتون الثمار تحت الكبريت
رعاية الأحداث عندما
يكونون أكثر عرضة للحيوانات العاشبة ولضوء
الشمس ومن ثم نقل هذه
المزارع إلى أنظمة مختلفة حيث
يمكن حمايتها
وحمايتها يمكن أن توفر
فرصًا جديدة للسياحة
المستدامة وتساعد في جعل الحفظ أولوية وطنية
يقول tsaneen أننا بحاجة  حوافز
للناس لرؤية هذا كفرصة اقتصادية
أيضًا ليس فقط في كوكودا
لأن نخيل كوكودا
يكبرون ويموتون في
هذا القرن ولكني أعتقد أن احتمال
نمو هذا موجود ولكنه ليس كذلك
تم تطويره
قبل كل شيء ، تأمل سانين
أن ينمو زملاؤها الكولومبيون ليحبوا هذا
الرمز الوطني بقدر ما
أعتقد أننا ككولومبيين نسمع
أننا نسمع أحيانًا أن
كولومبيا بلد شديد التنوع
البيولوجي وأعتقد أن نخيل الشمع يولد هذا
فريدًا  البيئة والمناظر الطبيعية التي
يمكن أن تساعدنا في تحديد ما نحن عليه
وما لدينا لتقديم هذه القنابل الشمعية الهائلة
التي تغير تمامًا  انه منحدر
خيال رائع منظر
[موسيقى]
أجنبي